good morning John suddenly along with
the disaster in Japan has become kind of
necessary to understand a little bit
about how nuclear reactors work and so I
hope that you will excuse me postponing
my thoughts from Haiti and instead
giving in a direction to how a nuclear
reactors work and how that pertains to
the situation in Fukushima right now so
first things first you are welcome to
say nucular but you should know that
there will always be a certain
percentage of the population who will
assume that you are a dunce
I personally have no problem with
nucular but if you want fewer people to
think you're an idiot probably should
just switch over to nuclear now for
terminology one nuclear pertaining to
the nucleus which is the center of the
atom that contains the protons and the
neutrons nuclear reaction a reaction
that changes the nucleus this happens
either by an atom splitting apart or by
two atoms fusing together radiation is
any particle or wave that goes through
the air or goes through other things
besides the air like your body it's
generally when we're talking about
nuclear radiation we're talking about
ionizing radiation which is the kind of
radiation that has enough energy to
ionize an atom radiation can be harmless
but it can also be not harmless
radioactive decay this is important it
will come up again soon is when an
unstable atom loses energy by emitting
radiation
fission when an atom breaks apart into
two or more atoms that are an entirely
different kind of atom than the original
atom during fission a great deal of
radiation and energy is expelled and the
fusion products which are whatever's
left over are always lighter than the
original atom now where did that mass go
was converted into energy in a way that
is described by a very famous equation
notice in that very famous equation that
we are multiplying by the speed of light
squared you may have noticed the speed
of light very big number and so when you
convert a tiny tiny amount of mass into
energy you get a great deal of energy
which is why something in my ear a pound
of uranium-235 can be converted into as
much energy as about a million gallons
of gasoline speaking of which
uranium-235 is a rare isotope of uranium
that has very unique properties first
very unique property when you hit it
with a neutron doesn't even have to be a
special neutron it fission second when
uranium 235 splits it creates more
neutrons which then go on to hit more
atoms of uranium 235 which then go on to
create more neutrons which then goes on
to create a chain reaction that can be
turned into either a nuclear bomb or a
nuclear energy reactor so in a nuclear
power plant you have uranium-235 and you
have it mixed into these ceramic pellets
and through the majesty of science these
little guys can never explode like a
nuclear bomb these pellets are placed in
the tubes of zirconium alloy that is
extremely strong and heat-resistant that
tube with the uranium pellets in it is
what we call a fuel rod when a bunch of
these rods are close together the
uranium begins to fission creating
energy and radiation and neutrons and
fission products which are the stuff
that's left over after the uranium
splits apart all of this stuff is what
is called the reactor and it's encased
inside a thick steel box like eight
inches thick steel that steel box is
called your primary containment and then
that is inside of a giant concrete and
steel box which is your secondary
containment so when the reactor the fuel
rods are hot water is pumped through the
fuel rods it turns into steam the steam
drives a turbine the turbine creates
electricity and that is how we get
electricity from nuclear power now if
you want to turn it off we have what are
called control rods control rods absorb
neutrons you stick them in between the
fuel rods and it absorbs all the
neutrons own neutrons are left to
continue the chain reaction and the
reaction stop ideally that would be
where it ends but it's not because we
have those fission products all of those
fission products left over from the
uranium splitting are unstable isotopes
and this is where we come back to
radioactive decay because they are
unstable isotopes they decay and as they
decayed they produce radiation and
energy and that energy becomes heat and
it's not nearly as much heat get in the
center of a reactor when it's running
but it is still a lot of heat in fact it
is so much heat that if you don't cool
it down the fuel rods themselves will
eventually break and you will have what
we call a meltdown and this is what
happened in Fukushima as soon as the
earthquake happened the control rod
slammed into place the reaction stopped
but we still had the fission products
creating a lot of heat the grid power
made
got taken down by the earthquake and the
backup diesel generators they got wiped
out by the tsunami and so there was
nothing left to power the coolant system
the system that keeps water running
through the reactor so that the fuel
rods don't get too hot they don't break
and they don't melt down so it appears
that some of the fuel rods did break
that created an environment combined
with the heat that could actually split
water into hydrogen and oxygen creating
hydrogen which we all know is explosive
and we've seen the effects of that in a
series of hydrogen explosions throughout
the plant that have damaged both the
primary and the secondary containment at
at least one of the reactor additionally
just like the reactor when it's turned
off still produces Heat we have what are
called spent fuel rods these are fuel
rods that no longer contain any uranium
but they do contain all of those
radioactive fission products spent fuel
rods can spend years at the bottom of
giant pools while we wait for the
radioactive materials in them to decay
enough that they are not producing so
much heat that they cannot be dealt with
in a different way and the same way that
the cooling system for the reactor isn't
working the cooling system for those
spent fuel rod pools is also not working
there's another difference between the
reactor rods and the spent fuel rods and
that is that the spent fuel rods do not
have a primary containment vessel so
there is less protection and if the
water in those pools boils off the spent
fuel rods could meltdown create a fire
that would spew radioactive dust into
the air and it would be bad the men and
women who remain at the site trying to
keep the situation under control are
very literally risking and possibly
sacrificing their lives for their
country those Ben and women are made of
some tough stuff and I wish them a great
deal of luck in getting this under
control
you'll notice that throughout this video
I have not been making judgments about
whether or not we should be using
nuclear power because I simply do not
know I can see and understand both sides
of this argument very well I do not know
whether or not the benefits of nuclear
power outweigh the risks I do know that
most of the ways that we generate the
majority of our power now are dangerous
and bad but that we need electricity for
our society to function and for people
to be happy and healthy and safe quite
frankly I think it's kind of ridiculous
that so many people seem to have made up
their minds about this issue when
obviously it's a very complicated one
it's almost as if our society values
opinions more than it values knowledge I
could only hope this
tuition simply doesn't get any more
severe than it already is and the people
working at their plight and the people
living nearby are able to safely return
to their homes in a relatively short
amount of time and I hope the people who
watch this video can understand a little
bit better the situation and not panic
unduly John I'll see you on Friday